I have been positively flamboyant about
my love for the pumpkin spice latte love
the pumpkin spice latte is it true I
would ask that you respect my identity
Megan it is a delicious drink it is
nostalgic it is is wonderful beer Isle
manliness within just aching to get out
that's what the pumpkin spice latte is
when you start raising the price of the
pumpkin spice latte I make no apologies
for it I think it's a delicious autumnal
treat it makes me remember that my
favorite season is coming around it
makes me just feel like I'm wearing a
big sweater and looking at nice orange
Maple Leaves some people are very upset
with me because they say Starbucks is a
woke Corporation and it's all lib and
it's overpriced and it doesn't taste
that good and you should ditch the psls
so look you know I try to keep an open
mind especially when you my beloved
viewers and listeners uh bring something
up to me so our producers have found the
absolute Locust Starbucks commercials
that there are they're going to play
them for me we're going to see if any of
them can get me to ditch my beloved PSL
let's get a Starbucks commercial
interview yeah an 8 PM crew and
an open a 5 000 fans yeah that's a
stressful schedule girl I need a coffee
thank you so much
look honey I've seen that you've cut the
line I am in line waiting for my skinny
latte like everyone else and I feel you
should do exactly the same and did
anybody ever tell you that excessive
amount of makeup during the day makes
you look really horrible skinny latte
extra phone listen honey your little
cutesy flurry thing is not gonna work
with me and you know what one more thing
lady you need to huh
thank you
[Music]
no until the very end until the shot of
the drag show out in public I have no
problem with that commercial that's not
even close to getting me to give up the
PSL because in a way I sort of like the
commercial it's making fun of
transvestitism Matthew how come a
transvestite donkey witch is standing
next to you and why is it wearing a
dress the existence of drag shows is not
what drives me crazy about our modern
era there has been something like drag
shows that have existed for all of human
history what drives me crazy is the idea
that the drag show is real life okay it
doesn't really bug me when men put on I
mean it's it's not great it's a little
bit decadent and probably not you know
great for them or for the culture but
when they put on these big crazy insane
outfits and then perform this ridiculous
caricature of their cartoon of a woman
that can be kind of funny what is not
funny what is just sad is when men
wearing the same outfits look you dead
in the eye and they say no I'm actually
a woman what are you talking about what
is silly about this why are you laughing
there's nothing funny about this I'm a
woman that's like crazy so the fact that
Starbucks leaned drag over you know
transgenderism that's fine by me I don't
like whether this stuff could be in
public where kids can see it where you
well you have to look at this stuff but
no sorry I'm keeping my PSL let's go to
the next commercial
hi I'm Mary we are currently in a
Starbucks I like the atmosphere here
everyone's always really nice really
welcoming nobody bats an eye that my
husband is transgender I'm by and gender
fluid so sometimes I'm a girl and
sometimes I'm like like my entire gender
is just like that Shifty hand motion my
dad I don't think he really understood
bisexual but he tried because he got me
this little like nightgown t-shirt that
said no boyfriend no problem and to this
day it's the best gay joke he's ever
made
okay that one's sort of just sad you
know their their Starbucks isn't pushing
some ridiculous sketch with giant men
wearing high heels and stuff
there they're pushing this idea that a
man can be a woman and vice versa and
that's just kind of sad the message is
Starbucks is inclusive of everybody
obviously Starbucks is going to be
inclusive of this transgender nonsense
the whole culture is what I find is not
often included in the pop culture is
conservatives
right Wingers people who kind of just
like dress normal and do normal stuff
there have been times when some Baristas
with crazy colored hair and tattoos and
piercings and stuff have looked at me
and clear you know I think maybe
recognized me and didn't love me so much
but there have been a number of times
where I've I've been to a Starbucks and
the Barista from around the corner will
kind of lean in and say hey
hey
I'm on the team I'm this I'm the same
I was like wait you're a conservative
here at Starbucks yeah it's big lib
place and we don't talk about it too
much but whatever it's cool it's a good
paying job okay they're gonna air their
stupid perfunctory
I assume pride month kind of transgender
thing I'll be real it's going to get me
closer to ditching my PSL if I see too
much more of that stuff we'll see what
the third commercial does you know my
schedule is very very busy especially
we're heading into speech season I'm
talking all over the country all over
the world actually and I can rest easy
because I love ring ring alarm the
protection afforded by ring alarm is
phenomenal I know what you're thinking
you're thinking Ring the video doorbell
company they have an alarm yes they do
ring alarm is an award-winning home
security system with available
professional monitoring when you
subscribe best of all you can easily
install it yourself even I can do it I'm
not the handiest guy in the world but
ring didn't even stop there ring has
changed the home security game with ring
alarm Pro when it comes to protecting my
home I love ring I've gone pro you got
to be a pro just like me okay ring alarm
Pro
is that whole home security system it's
got available professional monitoring
when you subscribe it combines a
security system with fast Eero Wi-Fi 6
router home security network security
your physical home your digital home you
protect it all with one device with a
ring protect Pro subscription which is
an amazing deal by the way I get
professional monitoring whenever I want
it for the ultimate piece of mind if
anything happens professional monitoring
can call you you can press emergency
services this season whether you're
traveling across the country for
speeches whether you're at your home
whether you're at the office make sure
you are protected with ring okay GoPro
learn more at ring.com Michael ring.com
Michael my enjoyment of the PSL hinges
on this commercial
since our beginning
we've looked to inspire and nurture each
other by asking what's possible
when we connect what's possible Caleb oh
when we open our hearts but you seem
like a good person to karaoke I'm pretty
fun okay
what's possible when we grow together
after 50
we've learned that possible is just the
beginning
okay the lesbian date was a little bit
much beyond that I have no problem with
that commercial commercial opens With A
well-dressed guy walking into Starbucks
and ordering a coffee and people being
friendly love that yeah it's true the
commercial checks off sort of every
identity Box by today's standards that
commercial is practically conservative
okay yes I know it's like kind of hippie
dippy and Kumbaya and Liv and like hey
you know hey guys eyes were all just
coming together you know and going on
lesbian day it's a goodbye today's
standards look frankly I think it is
relatively relatively conservative it's
certainly it's it's not woke enough to
get me to give up my drink
better luck next time guys hope you all
enjoy a delicious sugary fall cheers
[Music]
[Music]